hi there today we'll look at self
training with noisy student improves
image net classification
by chidze sie mintan luang eduard hovi
and kwok v
li so this paper takes an
imagenet classifier that's been trained
on the imagenet dataset
and uses that classifier as a teacher
model
to label a whole bunch of unlabeled
images
and then it trains a student model that
is larger than the original teacher
model on those teacher labeled images
and that turns out to improve the
classification
on the imagenet validation set now that
there is a couple of things that make
this
all work and today we're going to
explore how this paper does it and
what they say is important if
you enjoy content like this as always
don't hesitate to share it out or tell
your friends
about it and if you're not subscribed
yet then do so
um i would appreciate that and
you'll get more content so win-win
so this this paper is about
semi-supervised learning
in um in effect so it's at the
intersection actually of semi-supervised
learning
knowledge distillation and transfer
learning so what do we mean by
semi-supervised learning usually in
supervised learning you'll have
some sort of data set and the data set
will contain
let's say it's an image net it's image
data set so the data set will contain
images
this is an image with like some sort of
cat on it
and it will contain the labels according
to that
so cat now in semi-supervised learning
you you assume that so this is
supervised learning in semi-supervised
learning you assume that only
part of your data set has the labels so
like only this part down here has the
labels
and the upper part does not have the
so that's semi-supervised learning it's
often the case
when it's very expensive to get labels
so you can only get labels for a couple
of images
in your data set but very often in
semi-supervised learning you still
assume it's the same data set
there is a slightly different setup here
that's called transfer
learning so in transfer learning what
you'll have
is you'll have your data set that has
the labels
but it's very small so you'll notice
i've drawn it smaller
that means you have very little that is
also the case
when it's very expensive to get labels
but
also it's expensive to get the data
itself this is often the case like say
in medical data
where not only is it expensive to get
labels for
like a ct scan it's actually expensive
to get the ct
scan so what the goal in transfer
learning is
is to say well i do i do have
only this small data set but i do have
this giant other data set over here
now can't i it's not the same it's
maybe they're not ct so these are ct
scans maybe these are
x-rays right they're fairly
similar similar technology um if you
slice the ct
it will give you sort of an x-ray can i
you know train my model pre-train my
model on x-ray data
and then fine-tune it on the ct data
so that's called uh transfer learning
usually
now this can be done with or without
labels so it can be that
for the x-ray data set you do have the
labels or
you don't have the labels there are
techniques for
all of those now what we're going to
look at today
is kind of this situation right here
it's the transfer learning situation
where you do not have the labels for
this x-ray data set but other than in
this x-ray example what we're going to
look at is the small data set is going
to be our
imagenet database so our original
picture with label database so you'll
see immediately the difference here
is that in the transfer learning setting
we usually assume that the data set
we want to train on is fairly small
here you know imagenet is already
sizeable
but what we have is we have a much
larger database
of unlabeled images that we can just get
from the internet
so we can scrape the internet for any
kind of pictures
and that will be our unlabeled data set
and what we'll try to do is
somehow incorporate this unlabeled data
set here
into the training process to get better
on the imagenet data set
okay so this is the the problem
statement is you have the imagenet
dataset and you have a second
much larger data set of unlabeled images
and you somehow want to make use of them
so i hope you see how this is sort of
connected
to the others it's essentially sort of a
transfer semi-supervised learning
setting
but with the exception that usually in
transfer learning you assume that
the the labeled data set is like super
small
which is not the case here and that's
going to result in
us being able to apply a different
technique so this different technique is
called the noisy student
now usually what you might do in a
transfer learning setting is you might
want to start
with that big data set right because
that's the data set that's sizeable
enough to allow you to train
a really big model on it and then you
fine tune and you you sort of hope that
the information transfers over
here on the other hand what we want to
do is we start
with the imagenet data set so first
we train this in a supervised learning
fashion
into our model now this model is going
to be called the teacher model
we know how to do this we know to train
imagenet models right
so we can train this into a teacher
model that has a reasonable accuracy on
the imagenet data set
step two we're going to take that big
data set over here
and use the teacher model to label
the unlabeled images so for each image
for each image coming in here the
teacher
so maybe this is again another cat the
will say that's a cat okay
so that gives you the big data set
where now you have images along with
labels
just the labels aren't true labels
they're generated by the teacher
and then in the third step you train
this big data set you train on this big
data set
and that's what you call your student
model
and then the student model in this paper
will see
how can we make it such that the student
is then better
at the original imagenet task than the
teacher ever
was which seems counterintuitive at
first because all of the information
that the student is trained from
is basically what the teacher already
knows right all the labels here
come from the teacher therefore the
student shouldn't be able to
outperform the teacher but
in this case the student will be able to
outperform the teacher
and their argument here is that this is
mainly due
to the fact that you use noise in this
training procedure
so when you train the student what
you'll do is you'll use
noise and one of the types of noise is
that you
severely augment this data right here
in order to train the student now we've
known for a long time that data
augmentation
for example in the frameworks of
self-supervised learning and so on
can have a very large benefit to
training
and here the fact that we incorporate
this at extra data
and we use noise and augmentations on it
is going to result in a student that can
sort of learn more
about the data than than the teacher
did know
okay this this is basically it and
as you can see this is kind of their
main final result
where they say on imagenet our top one
accuracy
sort of increases right here and
uh even on these kind of subsets of
imagenet or these are sort of corrupted
sets of imagenet they make even more
substantial improvements as you can see
here now we'll go into
what these corrupted subsets are but you
know just
for now these here are very difficult
variants of imagenet they can be
severely corrupted or
or distorted and so on and you can see
that the model improves severely over
the previous state of the art
which basically means that this model is
more
robust and that's a direct consequence
of the noise
now one last thing i should say is that
the student here is also
larger than the teacher so that's also
one thing that makes the student better
so what you will make is
the student model is larger than the
teacher model as a model as the
architecture
so in combination with the noise right
here
with the noise in combination that means
the student model is probably able to
capture
more of the variance of the data it's
larger it has more parameters it can
learn more about the data
together with the noise
it can probably be a more robust and
that's what makes it generalized better
and we'll also see
as we see here it's more robust to these
transformations and it's also going to
be more robust to adversarial
perturbations
so the the technique again is uh
illustrated here
as as we said it's pretty simple first
so step one step one train the teacher
model with
label data as you would
step two you infer the pseudo labels
on unlabeled data step three
you make a student you make sorry
with step three over here train an
equal or larger student model
with combined data and noise injected so
they don't
they use the original label data here
and the
pseudo-labeled data right here in order
to train the student
but still this the student doesn't have
more information more label information
than the teacher had it simply has this
teacher labeled teacher labeled
unlabeled data
also to train on now the crucial part
here is
well first of all that the student can
be larger and second of all that there
can be
noise and the noise comes in three
different forms
so first of all you use data
augmentation
which we've already seen this is sort of
like random cropping
or mild rotations color jitter whatever
they use a rand augment here which is a
specific technique to apply these
augmentations
um they use dropout which is a fairly
old technique where
you in the student model that you train
you randomly drop out connections which
makes it more robust
and more generalizing and then you also
use stochastic depth now stochastic
depth is a technique when you train a
model
what you'll do during training instead
of always passing your data
forward through the layers like this you
use some sort of a
drop out but with entire layers so what
you'll do
is you'll pass your data forward and
then randomly
you'll skip a layer and then pass it
forward again
now these these might seem weird first
because uh
yeah it might seem weird but in if you
know that
most models especially computer vision
models nowadays
are residual networks which means that
their layers look like so you have the
input
you have some computation and then you
have the output and then there is
already a residual connection
that basically adds the original signal
together
to the result of the computation so all
you do
in this stochastic layer dropout or this
stochastic depth right here
is you basically disable use you disable
this connection right here
and all the signal has to flow through
here
if you read the residual the resnet
original resnet paper they make it
pretty clear
why the residual connection is a good
idea basically they say
these computations here they if you have
a very deep network
each layer only has to basically um
do very a little bit of computation that
that can be bypassed uh fairly
efficiently for
a lot of data points so it's not that
hurtful to bypass a layer
and in this case they actually use it to
just bypass
some of these small computations and
inject some more robustness into the
student
model so with these three strategies
to bring noise into the training process
one is on the data and two is on the
student model itself
they train the student model and then
fourth and this is what we didn't have
before fourth
or maybe we put four here
make the student a new teacher so now
you can iterate
you can use the student model that you
just trained to again
label the unlabeled data and then you
can use
another student model again under the
influence of noise to train
from that student model and so on and
you can go on and they do up to like
three iterations of this where they
always take the new
the student as the new teacher and then
use a new student model to train from
that teacher
and they get better and better as they
do this of course there's like a
diminishing returns but it's pretty
impressive that this
even works right the new students in
fact
aren't even larger than the old students
it's just that the students are larger
than the original
teacher model in most of these cases so
here's the algorithm
written down you'll require labeled
images
right here and unlabeled images which
are the ones with the
tilde so first you learn the teacher
model which minimizes the cross entropy
on labeled images
this we already know this right
this is the label this is the image
according to the label
and you train the teacher model which is
this thing here
and you can see here noised so already
in the teacher training process
you want to introduce this noise you
want to introduce these data
augmentations these are
as i said these are standard techniques
to make models more robust and therefore
more generalizable
yeah we know from these from these
self-supervised papers that these
augmentations are very powerful and the
way you design them
basically if you one of these
augmentations is a random crop which
means if you have an image you
randomly crop out like part of that
image and then
that's your training sample and not the
entire thing
so by doing this you basically
teaching the model to ignore the exact
location and scale
of things on an image and you can do
this because you as a human
know that you know i can zoom in i can
zoom out into something and it won't
change
what's on the picture and so
that's you use these augmentations to
kind of heuristically tell the model
what it should be invariant
to and that is that is a very powerful
technique
uh to regularize basically to to
robustify
these deep deep methods and this is used
the same here so already in the teacher
model we train
with these noise and then
step two use a normal i.e not noise
teacher model to generate soft or hard
pseudo labels for the clean i.e not
distorted
unlabeled images and this is important
they stress this here
that when you when you label the
unlabeled images
you want to use the model that is
without the noise
and you do it on the not distorted
unlabeled images so when you infer the
labels it's very important that you have
clean accurate labels without any sort
of
noise in them so label noise is not
something that they have found
to help in this case so not
label noise on the teacher that is so
you can see right here on the unlabeled
images
we'll use that teacher model without the
noise
um to infer the labels now they say
these can be
hard model hard labels or soft labels
so what does that mean if we generate
hard pseudo labels
that means that the y here is simply
going to be either 0
or 1 or 2 or 3 and so on so just the
index of the class whichever class is
most likely
that's going to be our label this is
exactly how the
supervised data sets come right so this
is what you'll think
first when you see that however soft
pseudo labels
means that the y will be a distribution
so instead of
being of class 0 it will be sort of
let's say
90 percent of class zero
but also five percent class one and five
percent
class two right so you'll output the
distribution
um instead of the just the label
and they have found that the soft pseudo
labels work
slightly slightly better than the hard
pseudo labels
okay thanks
so they use the soft pseudo labels here
because they work slightly better but
you can do it with hard or
soft labels the important thing is that
you use the teacher
to generate as accurate as possible
labels
for your unlabeled data
then third we've already seen this learn
an equal or larger student model which
minimizes the cross
entropy loss on labeled images and
unlabeled images
with noise added to the student model so
as you can see labeled images and
unlabeled images so we're in this
semi semi supervised learning setting
right now you take in both
together with noise and noise here is in
bold which means they stress it again
this is important
so you can see that the loss is composed
of two different
things these are the true images of your
original
model and you use that
and this means you noise the student
model
and that noise can be on the data or in
the model itself
and here also the unlabeled images that
you have labeled with the teacher
you do the exact same thing so you train
on both of these data sets
and step four is if you want to do
iterative training use the student as a
teacher and go back to
step two
now they have uh some more tricks when
they do this iterative training
they are also up the batch size during
the iterative training and so on so they
do
a lot of things to make the student
learn
something more something better than the
teacher
and i think this the whole paper it
doesn't
it doesn't state it explicitly but i
think the whole paper everything they do
here
is to kind of force or allow the student
to become better than the teacher by by
giving more noise
by making the student larger by making
the batch size for the student larger
and so on so you you want to sort of
inject as much invariance as you can
and that will make the student
learn more
so they say here noising student when
the student is deliberately noised
in its it is trained to be consistent
to the teacher that is not noised when
it generates the pseudo labels
in our experiments we use two types of
noise input noise and
model noise all right
first data augmentation is an important
noising method in noisy student
training because it forces the student
to ensure prediction
consistency across augmented versions of
an image
specifically in our method the teacher
produces high quality pseudo labels by
reading in clean images
while the student is required to produce
to reproduce those labels with
augmented images as an input
second when dropout and stochastic depth
function are used as noise
the teacher behaves like an ensemble at
inference time when it generates pseudo
labels
whereas the student behaves like a
single model
in other words the student is forced to
mimic a more powerful
ensemble model we present an ablation
study so this
it's a bit weird what they say here um
don't be confused
you use the dropout and the stochastic
depth
on the student model and they they say
here
if you do this the teacher behaves like
an ensemble at inference time
whereas the student behaves like a
single model
and yeah it's it's a bit of a weird
formulation but
it's it's true like the teacher the
teacher will produce
these same uh the label for
different pathways through the student
if you use dropout and
kind of stochastic depth and therefore
the student is
kind of required to approximate each
time each forward pass has a different
forward pass through the layers through
the connections with dropout
and it's forced to approximate that
teacher label with all of these
um different things so you see that you
you put in a lot a lot of techniques
so they have even other techniques um
there is
one additional trick and it's not and
it's not one
actually they have so many tricks and if
you look at their experimental setup
that it's crazy
like they describe exactly we reduce the
learning rate like this
and the batch size like this and so on
so to get state of the art on imagenet
it's not enough to just have
a good idea of a new thing to do what
you
you have to have the good idea and then
execute it
almost like really well um because you
have to
regard all of these additional tricks
that people have figured out over the
years
in any case they say it works better
with an additional trick
data filtering and balancing
specifically we filter images that the
teacher model has low confidence on
since they are usually out of domain
images so that goes to a point
where if you see we have this imagenet
label data set right
and we have the larger data set now
the larger dataset simply contains
images and there is no guarantee
that the images are actually of the
classes that we have in the imagenet
data set
right here we have a thousand classes
here there's no guarantee that
these images fit into any of those
classes
yet we still ask the teacher model to
put them in some of these classes
now you can filter out
part of those images um if you can
look at the teacher model and you look
at its confidence so when it outputs a
distribution
if if there's just two labels let's say
if it outputs a distribution like this
that's wildly different than if it
outputs a distribution
like this both are class 1 labels
but one is much more confident than the
other
so what you want to do is you want to
filter out these low confidence
labels because you know the model isn't
really sure but it has to assign a class
but that's usually an indication that it
is an out of
domain image so if they filter this
it works better and then also to ensure
that the distribution of the unlabeled
images
match that of the training set we also
need to balance the number of
unlabeled images for each class as all
classes in imagenet have a similar
number of labeled images
for this purpose we duplicate images in
classes where there are not enough
images
for classes where we have too many
images we take the images with the
highest
confidence
okay so this is just another technique
this has basically nothing to do
with their core idea but this is just
another thing
uh where they say okay we can treat
this big uh thing that we scrape from
the internet
you know we can somehow filter and
balance it smartly and that will work
even better
all right so let's go into
the experiments of course there um
so what they do i think where is the
graphic
what they do is they take an image net
sorry they take an efficient net right
here
and they trade they first train an
efficient net um
a smaller efficient net as we said
for to be the teacher and then they
train a larger efficient net
for the student
the best model in our experiments is a
result of
three iterations of putting back the
student as a new teacher
we first train an efficient at b7 on
imagenet as the teacher model
so you can see in the table right here
what the b7 achieves
the efficient net b7 here you can see it
has 66 million parameters which is
fairly small compared to these other
kind of previous state-of-the-art
methods on
imagenet right so they first train this
and that will achieve
something like an 85 percent accuracy
now if you just train a larger model
this efficient net l2 right here that
has
you can see 480 million parameters so a
lot of more mainly parameters but you
just train it
on the same data set on imagenet you
will get a 0.5
improvement and you can see that here
with noisy student training with the
exact same model so it has the same
amount of parameters
you'll actually get an 88.4
so i like a more than a three percent
improvement and that's with the same
model just with this different training
procedure
and inputting these 300 million
unlabeled images
that you have laying around but the
all the information about all the label
information
comes from the imagenet dataset and
comes from this efficientnetb7 teacher
model so that's
basically you can it's a testament that
out of this
out of this 85 you can make this 88
uh just by smartly using the information
that the model
that this model has learned about the
data and transferring it
to new data so they train
an efficient net b7 that's the small
model as a teach model then
by using the b7 model as the teacher we
trained an efficient net
l2 model with the unlabeled batch size
set to 14 times the labeled batch size
and they stress that it's important that
you up the batch size
that's another thing that makes the
student learn more than the teacher
then we trained a new efficient net so
by the way
these this 14 times it's also it can be
done because now you have more data
right so you can also up the batch size
then we trained a new efficient net l2
model with the efficient net l2 model
as the teacher lastly we iterated again
and used an unlabeled batch size of 28
times the label batch size
the detailed result of the three
iterations and so on okay so you can see
that it's a
fairly complicated procedure but you can
gain and
gain and gain by simply up upping the um
by simply upping the or iterating on
this procedure
and i think they have it somewhere here
yes
so as you can see if iteration
one you train the efficient net l2 you
start
it with the the b7 you train the
efficient at a2
with a batch size 14 times larger and
you gain
significantly right this gains about two
percent over the original efficient net
then you iterate again with the same
batch size and you get
uh like as a 5.5
improvement and you iterate again with
an even larger batch size and you get a
0.3
improvement so there's diminishing
returns but still you can see
that you know the more with the
introduction of noise with the
introduction of the larger model with
the introduction of the larger batch
size
these are all things that help the
student basically become better
than the teacher all right so they do a
bunch of other experiments so their main
comparison is right here where they say
look if we if even if we train the
same model with this noisy student
training we can make
you know pretty large gains over the
model
over the same model where we do not
train it with this
noisy student training so this really
seems to help
you know due to the noise due to the
additional data
they do a lot of ablation studies so
that's pretty interesting
and they also do these studies on this
special imagenet data set for example
imagenet c you can see
that there are quite a bit of
distortions right here i don't even see
if you can see it on this
video but this is a swing so the swing
right here is like something like this
but you almost can't see it and you see
that the
bold on the left is always the
prediction of their model
while the thing on the right is the
prediction of the original
model so this model they claim
is significantly more robust to these
kinds of perturbations
and they do an analysis of this
where they show yes in fact it is
[Music]
so i think we've already seen this at
the beginning that the noisy
student is significantly uh more robust
to these perturbations and they also
test this to adversarial perturbations
so right here you can see that the
original model drops pretty quickly
as you increase the epsilon the epsilon
is kind of the strength of the
adversarial perturbation
and the noisy the original model drops
very quickly
to you know fairly low accuracy while as
the
[Music]
noisy student training uh drops much
much
less quickly now this
um is another testament to the fact that
what you do
i think what's happening is you have
your data space
right and you have your data points in
it
now when you do the like normal data
augmentation
what you'll do is you not only force the
model to predict those points correctly
but you'll sort of make a bit of a cloud
around them and you
force the model to predict that cloud
correctly
now if you introduce more data
and you do even more noise what you do
is you'll make these clouds kind of
larger and that means the model is more
robust to any sort of perturbations in
these clouds right
and and that means it's probably also
going to be more robust to adversarial
perturbations
so that's sort of how you can think of
this uh this introduction of noise
uh to make it more generalizable how
does this generalize better
so if you think of this data point right
here if i'm looking to
generalize that means you know i have
this iid data set so
probably my test data is going to be
related to the training data so i might
get a data point
that's fairly close to that data point
and generalizing means i classify it
correctly
now if this cloud is very small like it
is here my decision boundary could be
like here right and even though the
tres test data set is fairly close to
the original
training data point it's it won't it
will be classified
uh incorrectly however if my original
cloud during training is larger you can
see if i train a model it can maybe put
the decision boundary here
and then my test data point will be
included
in on that same side so that's kind of
the idea behind generalizing better of
course that's a
vast simplification and also to say that
this here
is an fgsm attack so this is kind of the
weakest attack
in the adversarial perturbation spectrum
they do say under a stronger attack
pgd which is a fairly strong attack with
10 iterations at epsilon equals 16.
noisy student training improves
efficient net l2's accuracy
from 1.1 percent to 4.4 percent
and not this um like
you know 1.1 percent really means the
model
is almost like dead this is lower
this is like random performance and 4.4
is still a bit above random performance
but
um yeah you could probably you could
probably get there by
simply using any sort of noise
in that case but still you can see that
it
is more robust to especially to natural
distortions
and therefore it generalizes better
as i said they do quite a bit of drop
sorry not drop
out ablation studies to figure out where
exactly
um the performance comes from and the
answer is
it pretty much comes from all the things
that they've described
so here you can see um
the in the effect of that extra data set
and you can see pretty much with that
extra data set
all the all the situations improve
here you can see what do you what is
happening when you do not
augment the student uh when you do not
date to augment you can immediately see
that the accuracy drops
and then when you do not augment and
also don't use these model
noises then the performance drops again
and lastly when you use the teacher but
you noise the teacher
you can see also here the performance is
dropping from the original
um quite a bit so all of these things
kind of contribute and they do much more
ablations
and they have listed their findings here
so
using a large teacher model with better
performance leads to better results so
you know as the original teacher you
should use
as good as possible a teacher model you
can find
second a large amount of unlabeled data
is necessary for better performance
okay so if you want to do this you
better get a large
large amount of extra data because
that's
one thing that makes the student perform
better
soft pseudo labels work better than hard
pseudo labels for out of domain data in
certain cases
fourth a large student model is
important
to enable the student to learn a more
more powerful model
okay so because usually this um
knowledge distillation is what it this
this is usually called knowledge
distillation
if you use a teacher model to train a
student model
and it is often used when the student
model is smaller than the teacher
because you want to kind of become more
efficient
you from so the teacher is large you
make the student small
and you usually sacrifice some accuracy
and here they say if you want to gain
some accuracy
you need a large student model it can't
be like a small one
number five data balancing is useful for
small models
number six joint training on label data
and unlabeled data outperforms the
pipeline that first
pre-trains with unlabeled data and then
fine-tunes on labeled data
so this is in contrast to like what
people have done
before in the self-supervised learning
and so on
where it's always kind of pre-training
then fine-tuning or in the in the
transfer learning setting
seven using a large ratio between
unlabeled batch size and label batch
size
enables models to train longer on
non-labeled data
to it to achieve a higher accuracy okay
we've already seen that they have used
that and number eight training the
student from scratch
is sometimes better than initializing
the student with the teacher
and the student initialized with the
teachers still requires a
large number of training epochs to
perform well
this is fairly interesting because it
kind of alludes to the fact that
the minima in weight space
if so if this is of course the case if
the
student model is the same as the teacher
model so in like iteration two or three
or what not
um it means that you know in weight
space
if we look at you know you might want to
start the
student here and the minimum is right
here
and you might want to think that if i
learn the same thing
then the minima are fairly close
together right so the the teacher's
minima
might be here and the student minima
might be fairly close so it
might be beneficial if i if i start not
over here but actually start at the
teacher's
minimum but this doesn't always seem to
be the case
and that is a fairly interesting
observation because it kind of means
that we're talking about
different minima here we're talking
about the student model
learning different things and that's
what we've discussed already the student
model
kind of learns to be robust and that's
probably
a minimum that's fairly far away in
weight space at least in
in a sort of energy landscape weight
space uh
might be the case that it needs to
actually overcome kind of a
a hill here even though the minimum
might be close
there's lots of research in like how
minima are distributed in these weight
spaces
which i don't want to go into right here
but it is a fairly interesting
observation that it's not always helpful
to initialize
the teacher sorry the student at the
teacher's
optimum okay so
this was the paper and you know this is
this is the type of research
where i do appreciate kind of the these
large labs taking it on because they
have the resources to do
all of these ablations all of these
different models
cross them with these giant data sets
and so on which i guess
university labs just would not have
and this is a fairly um thorough paper
really investigating which parts of the
pipeline
you know do something and which ones
don't and
usually i i'm fairly critical of
pipelines that have like 50 billion
tricks um
because you never know where the
improvement exactly is coming from
but you can sort of mitigate that
criticism by
doing all of these kind of ablations on
the different parts and really showing
look
this is important but this is also
important but this is also important but
this is also important
so yeah that was my two cents to this
paper
i hope you enjoyed this and i'll see you
next time bye bye